now if we're talking about the absolute
best food to help you heal repair
especially after exercise but from
anything like stress trauma surgery
hands down the answer would be red meat
now I recently did a video talking about
different proteins which are a little
bit better for certain health conditions
maybe something's better for
anti-inflammatory Etc but when we're
talking about generalized healing and
repair
animal meat and specifically red meat is
at the top of the list because not only
does red meat have the most protein it
also has some other amazing things that
I'm going to share with you today which
is going to blow you away over 30 years
of practice I've never met one person
who ever had an allergy to meat okay
they might have had an allergy to
peanuts or eggs or seafood or shellfish
or wheat or soy
but not red meat and just the fact that
meat has been villainized right as the
bad guy uh you should start eating less
red meat as a way to get healthy or
overall it's going to be better for
climate change because we know the cows
are destroying the climate which is
completely ridiculous but right there
that one argument the fact that
mainstream is telling you not to do it
the truth is going to be in the exact
opposite direction in fact it's
difficult to heal and repair your body
without animal protein especially red
meat and today I'm going to prove it now
in past videos I talked about eggs and I
eat a lot of eggs and eggs are awesome
okay but if we compare eggs to meat
there is some significant differences
and that's what I want to talk about
today I've also talked about the benefit
of having salmon and fish which I also
have once or twice a week and salmon and
sardines are very high in omega-3 which
are good but beef red meat has more
protein and it has a lot of other things
that can help you heal if we look at the
whole picture I will say out of all the
things that are involved in the healing
process and the repair process we need
amino acids we we need bioavailable
protein which is going to be animal
protein and we need concentrated protein
and if we just compare red meat to eggs
red meat is twice as concentrated in
amino acids it also has 1.5 times
greater iron 2.2 times greater magnesium
3.7 times greater amounts of zinc and 50
times more vitamin B3 than eggs it has
double the amount of B1 four times the
amount of B6 twice the amount of B12 and
four times the amount of vitamin K and
five times the amount of omega-3 fatty
acids the ratios are going to be better
and of course I'm not talking about
processed meat from factory farms I'm
talking about grass-fed beef even if you
compare that to chickens that are
pasteurized they're still fed grains
which kind of throw off the omega-3 to
omega-6 ratios now that being said eggs
are also a good source of protein but as
a side note beef liver has 73 times more
vitamin A than eggs now there's another
nutrient that eggs have that's better
than beef and that would be choline it
has a little bit more than doubled
amount of B2 and a lot more folate it
has 12 times the amount of folate than
in beef beef has something else that I
think is like The X Factor actually it's
four things I'm going to mention and the
first one is carnitine it's this thing
that helps transport
bat into your cells into the energy
Factory called the mitochondria to help
you get more energy so without carnitine
the cells can't get energy from that
carnitine gives you that quick energy
when you're exercising and since we're
talking about a really important
transport of fuel to the mitochondria
that is essential for healing and repair
of your tissues so not only do we need
all the essential amino acids as the raw
material for proteins not just for your
muscles but for all your biochemistry we
also need other things as well like
those vitamins I just mentioned which
are cofactors but also the shuttle to
allow this raw material to give our
bodies energy so if we compare like 100
grams of red meat versus 100 grams of
eggs the amount of carnitine would be
like 150 milligrams versus only seven
milligrams for eggs but as far as the
food that has the most carnitine it
would be lamb but beef is number two so
this beef red meat is at the top of the
list as far as giving you a good source
of carnitine then we have creatine
creatine gives us that quick energy it
can be used as fuel for very very high
explosive intense movements both
exercise and physical activity needs
this creatine so this is why you see a
lot of bodybuilders and weight lifters
and people who do exercise taking this
as a supplement well guess what out of
all the foods that you could possibly
eat on planet Earth
red meat from beef has the highest
amount of creatine so creatine is just
going to give you more energy to heal
and repair from exercise now the next
compound I'm going to talk about
which by the way red meat from beef has
the absolute highest Source it's called
carnosine it buffers this pH okay from
the lactic acid the acidity in the
muscle so if you're exercising this
compound comes along and helps
neutralize this acid to allow you to
exercise longer because the pH messes
with some of the oxygen in the muscle so
it buffers the pH
it acts as an antioxidant and it's also
going to help the recovery after
exercise and just healing in general of
your whole body and it also even
decreases something called ages and I'm
going to give you this term I don't know
if you've ever heard it before it's
called Advanced glycation end products
and basically this is a fancy term for
when you have this sugar molecule that's
locked up with a protein molecule and
it's kind of stuck in the body so these
ages kind of plug up the body and they
interfere with the function and they
usually come from someone that's
consuming too much sugar well guess what
this compound helps get rid of those
things so it's considered kind of an
anti-aging thing it can help you just
live longer but out of all the foods you
can eat
red meat from beef has the most
carnosine and then we have coenzyme Q10
what is that that is a nutrient that
helps the mitochondria the energy
Factory where food gets converted to
energy now and the best source of
coenzyme Q10 is organ Meats like beef
liver for sure but it's also in the meat
as well it's also in fish it's in eggs
but it's mostly an organ Meats so just
in general
um when I was very very sick and I
stumbled on this ketogenic diet low carb
diet
buffalo burger was my first food that I
ate that I felt so good I actually
healed my body on buffalo burger and
hamburger in fact to this day I still
feel the best when I consume
um red meat in the form of hamburger now
I will do steak and things like that but
I do very very well on red meat in
general and if you're trying to heal
especially after exercise or you're
trying to repair from some type of
injury or trauma you should really
consider increasing more red meat and
having it more often and the cool thing
about hamburgers it has a little bit
more fat than some of the um like leaner
cuts of steak and there's only two
conditions that you need to know about
relating to
difficulty of digesting red meat people
that don't like red meat really have low
stomach acids and as someone ages they
get older they will lose their stomach
acids and the taste for red meat goes
down they can't really tolerate it and
there's this very simple solution just
add some obtained hydrochloride to the
meal I'll put a link down below you just
take three to five before a meal okay
you don't have to take it forever just
take it for a month and what will happen
is it'll start to increase the acidity
in your stomach you'll start to digest
the red meat much better and break it
down and start feeling better but when
people get older they just have a more
difficult time because they don't have
the stomach acid and they're also going
to have as a parallel thing gas more
indigestion definitely acid reflux gerd
those are all signs of low stomach acid
so instead of avoiding eating it just
fix the stomach's ability to digest it
and the one last point there is a
certain
genetic condition where someone has a
hard time getting rid of iron they tend
to accumulate iron and so if that is you
then maybe uh red meat is not the answer
you would want to do maybe poultry or
maybe eggs different protein sources
that have lower amounts of iron but for
everyone else I highly recommend red
meat even if you're going through a
menstrual cycle and you're losing blood
boy red meat is going to be the best way
to fix it because you're probably
slightly anemic and red meat has the
best iron and B12 in the best forms so I
hope I've given you more than enough
information to try this out to see if it
helps you but I consume a lot of red
meat in the form of hamburger on a
regular basis
and of course I kind of am lucky because
I get it from Animal Farm but you can go
get it from the farmer's market or you
can get it online from various sources
as well like one good source would be
U.S Wellness Meats I'll put a link down
below for them as well but if you have
not seen my video on protein related to
other specific body conditions I put
that up right here check it out